all right want to do an update on
YouTube's ad pocalypse August update
it's been a while since we've spoken
about this if you don't know I will give
you the 30-second summary we have our
YouTube revenue graph to show you you
will notice that the beginning of the
year was going really well near the
number 1 on March 31st YouTube turned on
a new advertising algorithm as a result
of some mainstream corporate media
articles written arguing that YouTube
that algorithm could not prevent ads
from showing up alongside offensive or
racist content we lost 99% of our ad
revenue it looked like things were on
the up and up as you see an increase
from points 2 to 3 on this graph and
that was sort of into the middle of May
unfortunately at the end of June and the
beginning of July revenue fell off of a
cliff as indicated by the number 4 on
this graph and we are currently now down
about 85% in terms of ad revenue
compared to where we were before really
bad for our show
I mean genuinely bad for our show
YouTube revenue was close to half of our
total revenue and 85% of that has gone
away this has not gone unnoticed by some
really good investigative journalists
Amanda Hess at The New York Times wrote
a really good article back in April
about how this has affected our channel
called how YouTube's shifting algorithms
hurt independent media you can find that
at david pakman.com slash press davey
alba from Wired magazine wrote a really
good article updating the situation in
May called want a better web here's an
idea
pay for it you can also check that out
on the press page on our website and
unfortunately I'm sort of operating
under the impression that this is the
new normal this is this is just what it
is we cannot rely on YouTube for the ad
revenue that we once did and we are
going to have to make it up other ways
and my goal is you know one way would be
all right let's start picking our
stories to be sure that we're going to
get the highest paying and biggest
number of ads available for those
stories and start not doing the stories
that might be considered not ad friendly
I don't want to do any of that crap
right I want to keep everything exactly
the way it has been do the stories
I want to do the way I want to do them
and I also want to keep doing all the
long-form pieces that we're doing which
are significantly more labor and staff
intensive we're talking about these 15
20 25 even 30 minute pieces that we've
been doing deep dives as we call them I
don't want to change a damn thing so I'm
coming to you for help okay there's two
really simple ways that you can support
the work that we do one is the the
simplest way really is to make a pledge
on patreon okay you can go to
patreon.com/scishow link is in the
description for this video you just hit
that red button which says become a
patron and you can pledge as little as a
dollar a month don't for a second think
that if you can only pledge a dollar a
month it's not worth doing because if
only five percent of our YouTube
audience made a pledge of a dollar a
month only five percent one out of every
20 of you we can laugh our way away from
the YouTube ad problem so even if it's a
dollar a month and certainly of course
you can donate any amount that you want
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
if you want to get extra stuff right if
you like the idea of making a donation
but you want stuff extra benefits then
you can look at membership membership is
on our website at david pakman.com slash
membership you can pick any membership
right whether it's a monthly membership
a yearly membership and after you hit
the red sign-up button you will see the
second page of the signup process has a
coupon code field and you can write in I
voted 17 all one word all lowercase
I voted one seven and that will save you
40% off of your membership we have made
good headway into starting to fix the
YouTube ad revenue problem I was
initially hopeful that we could have
this resolved by the end of August I
don't know if that's going to happen
which is why I'm coming to you for help
if you don't care about this program
right if you just don't give a [ __ ]
about what we're doing don't donate and
I can assure you there are many people
who are doing exactly that there are
many people who email me and they say as
Pat
I'm thrilled that this is going on
hopefully you'll be off the air soon if
you're not on that side and you have
even $1 a month to spare this is really
the time to pledge that dollar a month
and I will come back to you with an
update closer to the end of the month as
to how we're doing